to measure how your blades stand up
against flesh
Doug will cut through these fish Rich
yours is up let's put it to the test
[Music]
nice
it will cut yes it will it felt good in
the slice good but the recovery was a
little heavier but it still felt like
it'll give me a close shave good job
okay Matt you're up next are you ready
yep
[Music]
it doesn't cut and I'm a little confused
by that I don't know why it didn't cut
[Music]
foreign
it's got a very good feel to it it's
very light it's got a very nice balance
to it and
we'll cut
now for the kill test in this we have a
ballistics dummy that pretty much
simulates the human form organs and
tissues the katana traditionally has a
razor-sharp edge that allows me to find
the gaps in between the armor I'm going
to try that with your blade to see how
well it does Rich you're up first
foreign
let's take a look at the damage
the thrust and the slice went all the
way into the internal organs in here
and the kill shot went deep all the way
into the liver
I think on the kill test this will kill
okay map Europe
[Music]
definitely through the laceration he's
disemboweled here
a nice big puncture in here that
definitely will get the liver
I think it's past the kill test
you've both obviously brought deadly
Implements of War here but now
it's time to Lock and Load gentlemen
because for the strength test we're
leaving the forge we're heading to the
gun range
what
all right gentlemen this is the final
test for the forged and fire
Championship it's the strength test
your weapons will be tested on their
ability to split a bullet your swords
are going to be locked into a vice then
we're gonna fire a bullet at your blade
all right Matt you ready break it
three
oh yes yes
on that
your sword split a bullet
there's no damage on the Edge at all
held up extremely well that is a real
true sign of your craftsmanship thank
you very well done all right Rich you're
up next when I look at him set the gun
up and get ready to shoot that blade
there's a little bit of doubt in the
back of my mind thinking it may not
survive this three two one engage
[Applause]
I like it blade didn't even move
it splits the bullet I couldn't have
been happier there's no mark on the
blade at all held up perfectly no
chipping everything looks great thank
you
congratulations gentlemen you should be
proud of the work that you've done which
only makes the judge's decision that
much harder we'll see you back at the
forge
Matt rich
in just five days you have both forged
elegant and lethal Japanese katanas
but in this competition there can only
be one winner of ten thousand dollars
Matt
you are the forge to fire champion
congratulations
Rich you did not make the cut I wish you
had done a little bit more finished work
we let the handle get a little bit
skinny it was almost the same
proportions on each side so I know you
ran into a time constraint but it did
split a bullet and that's truly
something to be proud of I feel a little
disappointed but the better bladesmith
wants
well Matt congratulations you are the
fortune fire Champion you're going to
claim a ten thousand dollar check how do
you feel this is awesome your blade is
beautiful not only is it beautiful but
it's fast it's got so cleanly through
the fish and on the ballistic dummies
that Justice involved It For The Kill
test great job lay it aside I was really
impressed with your handle set up
symmetrically it was correct we'd get
good control good grip on it very nicely
done this is such a rush I want to drive
home and kiss my son I'm the forge and
fire champion